[Music]
thank you
John and Freddie thanks for joining me
Freddie you write for the magazine this
week about how having a Republican
president could change America's
position on Ukraine under Joe Biden the
U.S has spent more than 70 billion
dollars helping Ukraine how would a
Republican president and I think more
specifically in this piece a trump
president change that
well I think Trump's made it very clear
uh what he intends to do he said that um
he says three things about it he says
first of all if he were President Putin
never would have invaded Ukraine it's
impossible to say whether that's true or
not
um secondly he says Europe's not paying
enough America's paying far more than
Europe to the war effort and he'd make
the Europeans pay more
and thirdly he says he would resolve the
conflict within 24 hours within a day of
entering the White House and I think
what's quite interesting about this is a
lot of hawks on the British side on the
NATO side and in America on the
Republican hawkish side the Republican
party uh worried that he actually might
do that uh but to their mind that would
mean making concessions to Russia uh
rewarding Putin's aggression as they put
it which would then encourage Putin to
uh be even more aggressive in the future
possibly with other states the baltics
and so on uh and I thought it was
interesting very telling this week that
Boris Johnson who's now become a sort of
global cheerleader for the for the war
effort went to Texas to talk to some
rich uh Texas Republicans and some
politicians and to sort of G them up to
say that you are still backing the right
horse Ukraine's going to win this fight
there's going to be a magnificent
counter punch this summer and the
Russian military will collapse I suspect
a lot of people at lunch believed him he
makes the case very forcefully the
difficulty for the Republican party is a
lot of their voters and the polls show
this a lot of their voters are not
aligned with that position on Ukraine
and as this election approaches that's
going to come into sharper Focus Fred
you mentioned there that Trump says
things like if I had been president
Russia would have never invaded on
comments like that comments that he can
end this war in 24 hours do you think
the public buy it well I think that
points towards a golden rule of
Republican campaign Dynamics now which
is that Trump can say anything and get
away with it and other candidates can't
right for instance Ron DeSantis uh
recently a few weeks ago uh found
himself sort of boxed in on the question
of Russia because I think by Instinct
he's more of a conventional more of an
atlanticist
but he was pressed by the now sacked Fox
News host Tucker Carlson to say what
what is America's national interest in
fighting Russia and Ukraine or being
involved in the war in Ukraine and he
replied he said it's not a vital
National Security interest for America
to be further entangled in Ukraine and
he was much criticized for that in the
media and it didn't result in the
Republican base uh rallying towards him
in fact if anything I'm sure there are
lots of other factors involved if
anything his polling has declined since
he made that statement but Trump can say
I'll resolve it in 24 hours and he gets
away with it because nobody sort of asks
him the further questions it needs to be
even on CNN a hostile interviewer only
wanted to ask him do you want Ukraine to
win and he said I just want people to
stop dying and the crowd in New
Hampshire broke into Innovation uh the
most sensible question I think to ask
him would be how exactly are you going
to do that right indeed um we'll come
back to Florida's governor he's had a
big week but John I want to bring you in
you're of course known for saying that
NATO should take some of the blame for
what's happening happening in Ukraine
but let's pivot specifically to their
Republican party position here what is
the mainstream Republican opinion about
Ukraine and how big is this issue going
to be the issue of the war in the 2024
election
I think you have to distinguish between
the elites and the public and it's very
important to understand that what the
public thinks here in the United States
just doesn't matter very much the elites
just do what they please
there's no question that there are a lot
of doubters
in the public both on the Republican
side and on the Democratic side and it's
likely that the number of doubters will
grow with time but the question is how's
that going to affect the elite and the
argument that's being made is that the
Republicans are beginning to go soft on
Ukraine at the elite level and that if
Donald Trump gets elected there's a
really good chance uh that he'll pull
the plug on the ukrainians
this is not going to happen in my
opinion
the United States
is backing Ukraine to the hilt and if
the United States withdraws its support
for Ukraine its material support Ukraine
is going to collapse it can't stand up
to the Russians the Russians would win a
big victory
it's hard for me to imagine that any
American leader whether it's Donald
Trump or Joe Biden is going to allow
that to happen it's just not going to
happen we are too deeply committed to
this War uh there's too much
russophobia in the United States there's
too much talk about the fact that this
is an existential threat that we're
facing with Russia for us to cut and run
and allow Ukraine to go under
furthermore just think about what the
consequences will be for China our
credibility people will argue will be
destroyed if we allow Ukraine to lose so
I think Trump
talks a good game
but what he actually does when he's on
in office assuming he gets reelected in
2024 is another matter and I would note
here that there's a final point that
Donald Trump when he ran for president
and in his initial few months in the
White House said that he wanted to
improve relations with Russia he viewed
Putin as a friend he wanted to put an
end to Nato and get out of Europe none
of that happened and in fact what did
happen is that in 2017
it was Trump who started arming the
ukrainians Obama much to his credit had
the good sense not to harm the
ukrainians but Trump decided to arm the
ukrainians and we were as tough on the
Russians during the Trump Administration
as we were in any other Administration
so Donald Trump can talk all he wants
about how he's going to do 180 degree
turn regarding American policy on
Ukraine but in my opinion that's not
going to happen if he gets reelected
you mentioned there that you think more
fatigue will set in when it comes to the
war in terms of American opinions of it
South Carolina Senator Tim Scott has
just launched his presidential campaign
uh with a very different view he thinks
that Joe Biden has not done a great job
of explaining to the American people why
the interventions have been so
substantial in Ukraine but that there is
a case to be made if you look at polling
numbers in the states right now they're
certainly increasing debate between
Americans about just how long the U.S
should be supporting Ukraine a debate
between say one to two years and then
indefinitely but there does still seem
to be a lot of support a majority of
support for helping Ukraine
there's no question about that uh and uh
it's hardly surprising if you look at
how we talk about Russia in the United
States and in the west more generally
these days
Vladimir Putin is portrayed as the devil
incarnate there's extreme russophobia in
the land and the Biden Administration
and the establishment foreign policy
establishments in the west more
generally have done a brilliant job of
propagandizing uh this war so it's
unsurprising that uh large chunks of the
body politic and all these Western
countries are committed to seeing Russia
defeated
do you think it's propaganda
again Port Ukraine or is it the fact
that they watched Vladimir Putin March
his tanks over the border into Ukraine
no it's clearly the propaganda campaign
it's truly amazing the extent to which
our discourse here in the west is
limited
so that we end up supporting the
ukrainians at every turn and opposing
the Russians at every turn there's
hardly anything that's ever said that's
positive about the Russian effort or
that's a possible explanation in
Russia's favor for why this war happened
this is a truly outstanding case of
extreme propaganda the only case that I
think comes close is what happened in
both Britain and in the United States
during World War One you want to
remember that in World War One there was
no equivalent of Pearl Harbor or 9 11
that brought us into the war and as a
result Woodrow Wilson had to go to Great
Lengths to mobilize the American public
to back the war this was especially true
because the two biggest ethnic groups in
the United States at that point in time
were German Americans and uh Irish
Americans and Wilson was deeply fearful
that the German Americans would not
fight against Germany and the Irish
Americans would not fight with Britain
so we launched an amazing propaganda
campaign
and uh I think that since then there has
been no equivalent to that propaganda
campaign until recently when Russia
invaded Ukraine and we have gone to
Great Lengths to portray uh the Russians
in the most negative light and to
silence people who might have a somewhat
different View and that would include
someone like me of course
Freddy Trump used to get a lot of
criticism when he would go and shake
hands with these dictators and human
rights abusers and his argument would be
well look at the results don't look at
the handshake look at the results I am
moving America away from this heavy
interventionist foreign policy and he
would claim he was successful indeed I
think and he certainly moved the
Democrat Party into a more isolationist
point of view
um do you think one of the reasons he's
so hesitant to say how he would actually
do what he's pledging to do to bring the
war to an end in 24 hours is because
those handshakes would not be feasible
now he would not be able to Buddy up to
Vladimir Putin in the same way he would
have to take more hostile approach and
frankly that that could lead to results
that
um that lead to very different results
than what the president is promising I'm
not sure I think Trump's approach is
always the sort of real estate uh
approach to to foreign policy which is
you know you make deals you take
positions you you deceive people with
your positions if you have to
um and I think where Trump is effective
as a campaigner is that he often says
things that Americans think but no one
in the public eye or no one in the
elites if you like uh will say so he
there's a famous moment when he was
asked about
um foreign authoritarian governments
doing terrible things and he said do you
think we're so innocent uh and this was
taken as a very anti-American statement
but actually I think a lot of Americans
know that their government has not done
uh has done terrible things in the world
and and they're quite honest about that
um so I think he has a he has a
rhetorical ability with it his
deal-making ability as an as an
Statesman is I think as John suggests uh
much exaggerated but you you know the
fact that he would be willing to talk to
Vladimir Putin is willing to say that he
would be willing to talk to Vladimir
Putin is does make him a different type
of politician to a lot of the other
candidates Freddie this week Florida's
governor Ron DeSantis has launched his
presidential campaign on Twitter and if
anyone's going to be a challenger to
trump it is thought at the moment anyway
that Ron DeSantis will be that person
and even if we just break this down into
name recognition some of the other
candidates running Don't Come Close
with his policy towards Ukraine be much
different from Donald Trump's well his
recent statements on it suggests that no
it wouldn't
um but he'd certainly talk about it more
in the language of international
statesmanship he wouldn't be saying I'll
just make a deal with
uh Putin and you know because I know his
strengths and weaknesses and I know
zelenski's strengths and weaknesses and
so I'll just I'll fix it
um he'll talk more about International
interests and the national interest
and I think so far it looks as though he
knows that the conservative basically
wants to Rally are much more skeptical
about what America's doing in Ukraine
than the rest of the population and so I
think for now he's he's tilting towards
Trump Tim Scott on the other hand is
tilting towards the more hawkish
position and talking about you know it
being a national interest to degrade uh
Russia's military so that it can avoid
an attack on UK's Sovereign land uh I
think that's a that's a an odd position
and I think a lot of Americans will
think it's an opposition because they'll
think well how is is Russia really
threatening American sovereignty and is
not the war that is currently being
conducted increasing the likelihood of
the only feasible albeit unthinkable
will attack on America from Russia which
is a nuclear one which of course would
be the end of the world
could I quickly just respond to
something that Freddie said
I think he's exactly right that Trump
views himself as a deal maker and he
thinks that he can move in here and he
can talk to Putin he can talk to
zelenski he can use pressure on zelenski
and he can cut a deal
the problem that Trump faces is not
simply that there would be resistance
from the rest of the establishment if he
tried to do that the problem the real
problem is there's no deal to be had
here right
nobody can figure out what the solution
is to shutting this conflict down and
there are two reasons for that one is
the territorial issue the Russians are
not going to give back the territory
they've conquered and the ukrainians
want that territory back and you can't
square that Circle furthermore the
Russians want Ukraine to be a neutral
State and Ukraine wants a security
guarantee and that can only come from
the west and you can't square that
Circle so there is no deal to be had so
you know there's all this talk these
days about using the Chinese as a as a
forced or as a moderator to work out
some sort of deal that's not a viable
argument because again it has nothing to
do with the Chinese it's the fact that
there's no deal to be had so Trump can
talk till he's blue in the face about
cutting a deal but there's no deal to be
had
but he would and John obviously you're
the great expert on international
relations so I defer to you on this but
he would have leverage I mean Americans
power is unrivaled uh he would have
significant leverage over Ukraine
because of the support that America has
provided uh Ukraine and he would have
significant leverage over Russia because
of the threat that America Campos to
Russia and the fact that the war has not
been going according to Russia's plan so
far
I think you're absolutely right that he
would have significant leverage over the
ukrainians not total leverage but
significant leverage but I don't believe
he'd have any leverage over the Russians
the Russians don't trust the Americans
whether it's Trump or Biden as far as
they can throw them and the Russians
have a deep-seated interest in taking as
much of Ukraine as they can uh and
turning the remaining part of Ukraine
into a dysfunctional rump State and the
promises from Donald Trump that they'll
work out some sort of meaningful deal
and therefore the Russians can make
concessions it's not going to wash the
Russians no longer trust us and they
shouldn't trust us
there's also a question about what would
happen to president zielinski if he did
come to the table and walked away with a
deal that your average Ukrainian did not
think was acceptable they could well
oust him and bring in somebody else it
strikes me that there's no guarantee
that either side frankly would
necessarily declare this war over even
if president Trump did I I agree with
that and I think it's not your average
Ukrainian it's the ultra right in
Ukraine there has long been a powerful
ultra-right a nationalist right in
Ukraine uh that wants to make no
concessions to the Russians and is
heavily into de-rucification of uh
Ukraine and those people uh would be
very hard to get on board and
zielinski's had his problems since he
was elected dealing with those people so
I agree completely without you
completely with what you say your
average Ukrainian of course has has also
been out there fighting I mean clearly
there is still support
amongst the country for for trying to
defend what what they want to keep and
but Freddie my last question to you is
if Trump were to become president and he
were to implement his agenda I think
we've established a lot of question
marks over that agenda
um what would other Western countries be
able to do would they be able to keep
supporting Ukraine would they be able to
do this without the United States I mean
I think a trump second Trump presidency
would be a Graver threat to Nato uh than
the first presidency was there was a lot
of fear about
um NATO uh being Trump was going to tear
NATO apart and so on because he didn't
really see the point of it uh in his
first term he just was agitating for for
other states to contribute more money he
didn't want America to pay so much I
think in the second term
with this situation in Ukraine with all
the pressures going on uh I think it
would be a Graver threat to Nato uh I
don't make any moral judgments whether
that's a good or bad thing uh I just
think that would be the dynamic
[Music]
thank you
foreign